. Hey! Hallo Berlin! Berlin, was geht's? Hey, hey, hey! Alle da! Dankeschön! Schön, dass ihr da seid! Yes! Vielen Dank! Dankeschön, noch ist nichts passiert. Das kann jeder Achtjährige, noch ist gar nichts passiert. Beruhigt euch! Extra für euch, nach Berlin gekommen, Florentin Will! Yes! Dankeschön! Und der Mann, auf den ihr jetzt drei Jahre lang gewartet habt, heute ist er hier, es ist Stefan Dietze! Er ist da, wir haben es geschafft, hier trug der Saal. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass Sie da seid Herzlich willkommen, dass Sie noch in einen Terminplan geguckt haben, was heute Abend war, als Sie es vor drei Jahren betrunken eingetippt haben. Wer hat gedacht, dass Tickets behalten ihre Gültigkeit eine Lüge ist? Das war die wichtigste Frage, mit der wir uns drei Jahre lang umgeschrieben haben. Können wir euch anlügen? Gehalten Tickets wirklich ihre Gültigkeit? Ja. Ist das dabei? Die Antwort lautet ja. Ja. Hat doch geklappt, oder? Hat irgendwer Probleme gehabt mit dem ungültigen Ticket? Nein! Nein, weil die, die es hatten, sind nicht hier. Ja, naja, gute Zielgruppe. Na ja, stimmt, richtig. So läuft das. Ich habe heute, ich habe Bock, heute alles zu geben. Ich will heute alles geben. Warum hast du direkt die Bühne verwüstet, wie so ein Rockstar eigentlich? Weil ich glaube... Unnötige Aggression auch direkt zu Beginn. Ich habe Angst. Solltest du auch. Ich glaube, wir haben heute Talentcoaches da. Und ich will heute einfach alles zeigen, was ich kann. Ich will alles zeigen, was ich kann. Ich kann kämpfen, ich kann springen. Ehrliche Frage, ehrliche Frage. Vor welchen Talentcoaches aus dem deutschen Fernsehen hättest du wirklich Respekt und richtig jetzt Angst davor und willst gut performen? Ralf Zacher, einer der Koch-Talent-Couches, die es überhaupt gibt. Ich liebe immer in so Dokumentationen, das schönste ist immer dieser Satz vom besten Curling-Spieler der Welt, er wurde durch Zufall durch einen Talent-Coach entdeckt. In welcher Situation? Wie genau lief das ab? In welcher Situation? Ich finde vor allem gut, dass du curlst, wie du bowlst. Ja, ja klar. Und ehrlich gesagt, vielleicht ist es auch besser als dieser Scheiss, weil die checken nicht, dass sie ja mehr Reibung haben, wenn die direkt das absetzen. Deswegen ist ja die Idee einfach, wahrscheinlich ist Werfen einfach die beste Hilfe. Ja, die könnten sich mit diesen Diskuswerfern zu tun, zusammen tun, einfach werfen. Nee, aber das ist nämlich der Punkt, ich versuche heute so viele Talentscouts, wie es geht, anzusprechen, indem ich Sportarten zusammenlege. Und wenn ich euch mal meinen Boardingwurf zeige, bap, ging er auch für Curling durch. Da werden die Augen gross hier in der zweiten Reihe, oh, da sind die Talentscouts. Aber er nickt nicht so richtig stolz, es ist mehr so, ah fuck, da wurde mir mehr versprochen von dem anderen Scout, der dich geprescoutet hat. Ja, und die Frage ist, wie ist es als Talent-Scout? Also bist du jetzt privat hier und hast die Augen gar nicht offen nach Curling-Talenten oder ist es ein 24-7-Job, so ein Talent-Scout? Vor allem Curling! In welchen Situationen kommt man denn auf die Idee, ich werde jetzt Curling-Profi? Mama, ich habe mir überlegt, ich werde Curling-Profi. Und diese macht was Läuftiges. Ja, Entschuldigung, Frau Tietze, ich hatte gestern die Ehre, an Ihrem Sohn vorbeizufahren mit meinem Auto. Stefan oder Michael? Nein. Oder Jimmy? Machen Sie sich keine Hoffnung, aus Jim wird niemals was, Frau Tietze. Nein, ich bin an Ihrem Sohn Stefan vorbeigefahren, als er gerade die Einfahrt gekehrt hat.
Stefan, hör mir auf mit Stefan.
Ich muss Ihnen etwas über mich sagen, ich bin nämlich Talentscout für Curling-Teams.
Und Ihr Stefan ist das grösste Talent, das ich seit Jahren gesehen habe.
Es ist kein leichtes Leben als Curling-Spieler, Sie werden ihn wahrscheinlich nur noch 300 Tage im Jahr sehen können, die restlichen 60 Tage dann auf Eurosport, aber es wird hart, es ist eine andere Art zu leben. Sind Sie auch noch für was anderes Talent, Coach oder? Ja, Imkerei auch noch und Golf, komischerweise. Ich kann Ihnen ja erzählen, wie ich...
Weil Eurosport ist bei irgendwie 89 auf meiner Fernbedienung.
Ach so, das müssen Sie vorlegen.
Ich kann Ihnen ja die Geschichte erzählen, wie ich eines Tages Talentscout wurde.
Entschuldigung, Frau Will.
Ja, hi.
Ich bin gerade mit dem Auto hierher gefahren und ich habe Ihren Sohn Florentin in der Einfahrt sehen. Florentin oder Michael? Herr Will, bitte, Frau Will, bitte. Aus Michael, aus... Did you just assume my gender? Entschuldigung, aus Ihrem Sohn Michael wird nie was. Ja. Es gibt ja etwas, das ich Ihnen sagen muss, ich bin nämlich Talent-Scout, Talent-Scout. Wirklich? Und Ihr Sohn Florentin ist der beste Talent-Scout, den ich je gesehen habe. Mega. Ihr Leben wird sich nicht verändern. Wir sehen uns, tschüss. Aber so muss es gehen. Er hat einen normalen Job. Ich weiss nicht, wie es sonst geht. Muss es geben. Niemand? Okay. Vor allem ist TalentsScout nicht nur ein fancy Name für Personaler in? Ja, im Grunde schon. HR-Referent. Ja. Ist jemand sowas? Ist jemand grob, Personal, Traum? Du bist gut, du bindest die Leute ein. Ist jemand Talent-Scout tatsächlich? Ja, du beschließt die Leute mit deinen Roundhouse-Kicks. Ich wollte denen Fragen stellen. Ist jemand so etwas wie ein Talentscout? Nein. Wer hätte das gedacht? Aber ist es wie bei den Undercover-Polizisten, dass die nicht sagen dürfen, dass sie Talentscout sind? Ja. Aber auch bei den Polizisten glaube ich das immer nicht. Nee? Ich glaube, es ist nicht so, dass sie nach den Zehen geboten handeln, wo du darfst nicht lügen, irgendwie einer der grossen, also du kannst doch sagen, ich bin kein Polizist, nein. Ich glaube, da ist einfach der Polizeicommissioner und der höchste Gangster der Stadt zusammengekommen und gesagt, das ist sau unfair, dass wir immer die Wahrheit machen müssen. Von großem Grenzen, dürfen Privatdetektive lügen? Oh, das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ist denn ein Privatdetektiv heute im Publikum? Nein, gar nicht. Ist ein Geheimagentepublikum. Ganz merkwürdig, komisch. Wir haben sehr viele neugierige Blicke da. Ihr habt uns alle schon gegoogelt, ne? Ihr habt uns alle schon gegoogelt. Ihr wisst, wer wir sind. Ich habe ja mal erzählt, glaube ich mal, irgendwann im Podcast, dass ich einen Kumpel habe, der sich beworben hat beim BND. Oh ja. Und dann auch in diese weitere Runde kam und dann wurde er interviewt und so. dann habe ich auch erzählt, dass er es nicht geworden ist und jetzt so einen langweiligen Job hat, wo auch viele Podcast-UFO-Fans geschrieben haben, sicher, dass er nicht den Job bekommen hat und deswegen diesen sehr langweiligen B-Controller in so einem Finanzkram Unternehmen irgendwie als Lüge vorschiebt, was ja wahnsinnig viel Sinn macht und seitdem glaube glaube ich unscheinlich wirklich, dass der beim WND ist. Ich glaube, es ist das Coolste, was man über sich erzählen kann. Viele von euch haben vielleicht eine bisschen langweilige Persönlichkeit und die können einfach irgendwann, also ich habe jetzt jemanden konkret angesprochen, in erster Reihe ganz mal. Du hast auf die Einzelne gezeigt, die ein Haartrans auf hat. Du hast auf die, offensichtlich auf die gezeigt, mit der coolsten Persönlichkeit. Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich glaube, es ist das Coolste, was du erzählen kannst. Keine Persönlichkeit hast du gerade gesagt? Gar keine Persönlichkeit? Und ich habe jetzt einen Tipp für die. Deswegen muss ich es durch Klamotten kompensieren. Ja, aber ich habe einen Tipp für die. Das kenne ich, bei dir auch. Ja, das stimmt. Wenn du dir gesagt hast, je flacher, desto cooler, hat man mir gesagt. Stand dir heute, ich bin ja wahnsinnig eitel, stand mit dem Lineal heute davor, Stefan hat mich ausgelacht, mit dem Lineal stand ich am Spiegel und habe versucht, meine Frisur zu packen. Aber, aber, halt das Mikrofon dran, das ist das beste Geräusch. Wann ist es zu spät jetzt? Ach Gott, okay, nichts klappt. Okay, ich habe einen guten Tipp für dich. Sag einfach, du hast irgendwann mal versucht, dich beim BND zu bewerben, und ab dann werden alle sagen, so, also was bist du vom Beruf eigentlich? Das ist deine, also, also, du musst es nur sagen, bei, Undercover-Polizist, bei Landscout und relativ, alles andere kannst du lügen, wie du willst, wenn du Tauchlehrerin bist, sag, musst du nicht sagen. Aber wenn jemand bei BND arbeitet, sag nie, will ich meinen echten Job jetzt haben? Ja, okay. Ich würde sagen, wir lassen dich mal einfach mal raus, damit du nicht Ärger mit deinen Chefs kriegst, weil er hat Recht. Es ist sehr verdächtig zu sagen, muss ich jetzt die Wahrheit sagen? Soll ich jetzt den echten Job sagen, bei BND oder den anderen? Ja, aber ich hatte natürlich auch einen Freund, der sich beim BND beworben hat. Also entweder... Moment, Moment. Ja. Reden wir vom Gleichen? Das war, ich meine, wie hieß es? Reden wir von James? James X, ja. Xie. War das nicht der? Ja. Aber da war es auch so, dass der dann irgendwann gesagt hat... Nein, nicht James X. Das war nicht die Referenz. Ach so, James Bond, Entschuldigung, sorry. Entschuldigung. James X. Da musst du aber erst Bond sagen und dann James.
So komme ich da nicht mit.
Mit deinen alten Leuten Referenzen komme ich nicht mit.
Ich kenne nur die coolen Rapper wie Peep X und so.
Aber den kennst du gar nicht.
So cool bin ich mit den Kids unterwegs.
Nenn mir mal deine coolsten drei Rapper.
All die coolsten drei Rapper.
Aber jetzt nicht irgendwie so achte Jahre.
Nee, nee, nee, ich bin up to date.
Ich bin up to date. Die Spotify Hotlist ist Max Mutzke. Lena Meierlandruth. Und wie ist der Typ mit der Uhr nochmal? Glocky Mac, Kloxen oder irgendwie sowas? Ich weiß es nicht. Typ mit der Uhr? Der Typ mit der Uhr? Flavor Flav. Ja, genau, Flavor Flav zum Beispiel. Guck mal, den kennt der Stefan nicht mal. Es ist teuer, es ist sehr teuer. Es ist sehr teuer. Es ist sehr teuer. Vorsicht. Wir sind sehr schlecht versichert. Aber es ist so, wenn wir jetzt kein Publikum gehabt hätten, hätte ich jetzt so drauf gemacht, dass du dir irgendwas ausdenkst oder sowas. Und das Willkommen zeigt mir, dass ich auf der falschen Seite der Geschichte stehe,
weil ich nicht weiss, wer Flavor Flav genau ist.
Vielleicht bist du gar nicht so cool.
Nee, habe ich auch nie behauptet. Das hast du gerade
so in dem Nebensatz mal gesagt. Bin ich.
Ich trage keine coolen Hosen auf meinen Shirts.
Okay, okay.
Auch für die Fashion Scouts heute,
ich bin noch zu haben.
Aktuell null Model Deals
momentan am Laufen. Bin frei, ich hab Zeit,
ich hab wirklich fast jeden Tag Zeit, egal wann ihr wollt. Bin jeder Tag für ein Fotoshooting zu
haben. Ausser die, wo wir Live-Shows haben, da will ich jetzt nicht, dass du vorher noch so
Model-Jobs hast und dich dann nicht konzentriert auf den Abend, auf unsere Vorbereitung, dass wir, wenn wir das Skript für die Show schreiben, dass du dann nicht kannst. Ja.
Was denn?
Das ist noch Quatsch.
Nee, wer ist denn Theis? Ach so, die hatten wir ursprünglich eingeplant, die hat es leider nicht geschafft heute, schade.
Ist gestorben. Also, und alle lachen. Thais kommt bald mal wieder rum. Ja, die kommt mal wieder rum, das ist so, weil die Thais nicht kennen, das sind 16-jähriges Mädchen, die wir als unseren Investigativ-Bluthun. Es war das dunkelste Kapitel der Podcast. Wir hatten eine Schülerpraktikantin, Thais, und sie hat auch noch Lust, was für uns zu machen, aber sie ist nicht mehr Schülerpraktikantin.
Und sie ist auch nicht mehr 16.
Nee.
Also es ist nicht so, dass Leute... Ja, ja.
Aber wir kommen in dieses Alter...
Ach, deswegen der Lacher, oder was? Reine Arithmetik war das. Der reine Mathehumor hier vorne.
Ja, ja.
Wow, okay.
Das war ganz schnell.
Stark.
29 minus 18.
Wohl doch nicht so schnell. Nice BND, Lady sofort. Niemand verstanden. Weil sofort, weisst du sofort. Die ist unterwegs, die lauert, die lauert in den Gassen, egal wo ihr seid, jederzeit kann, vielleicht ist sie unter uns, wer weiss. Thais muss nicht sagen, dass sie Thais ist, wenn sie angesprochen wird. Das ist ihre besondere Fähigkeit, sie kann jeden anderen Namen sagen. Seid. Aber warum, weil der Kumpel hat Politik studiert, ich bin noch nicht drüber hinweg. Warum ist das, warum muss er nicht irgendwie Parcours oder so Dinge, die ich mir vorstelle, die Agenten machen müssen? Kopf, sehr schnell im Kopf rechnen, so lösen, so Enigma-Rätsel lösen und sowas. Waren Sie als Kind sehr gut in dem Spiel Verstecken?
Hm.
Ja?
Okay.
Können Sie Geheimnisse bewahren?
Was ist für ein Bewerbungsgespräch? Kann ich mich setzen? Das war zu einer Strassenhecke einfach.
Warum haben Sie Ihren Arbeitsbürostuhl in die Ecke geborsten?
Hey, hey, hey, Hext! Brauchst du einen Job?
Nein, aber brauchst du Koks?
Auch, vielleicht können wir da einen Deal. Ich gebe dir einen Job, du gibst du Koks? Auch, vielleicht können wir da einen Deal.
Ich gebe dir einen Job, du gibst mir Koks.
Okay, was ist der Job?
Als, hey, hey, doppel, doppelschloss.
Saals.
Saalschloss.
Es ist nicht mein Geburts, es ist nicht ganz mein Geburtszeitrum.
Ist es eines Tages eine veraltete Geste, wenn es keinen Reisverschluss mehr gibt? Ist es so, dass Leute irgendwann nicht mehr... Ja, vor allem ist Reisverschluss jetzt auch nicht der sicherste Verschluss. Nee. Ich verstehe nicht, warum das das allgemeine Zeichen ist für, oh, der wird die Klappe halten. Ja, ja. Ist nicht so, dass er einfach sagen könnte, und dann hat Rebecca ... Genau, ich sag nichts. Vollidiot.
Dann hat Rebecca sie einfach als Schampe bezeichnet.
Vor allem, ich meine, wir haben auch die Geste Schloss.
Aber niemand macht das.
Aber ich frage mich bei jedem, der den Reißverschluss macht,
warum hast du nicht das Schloss gemacht?
Es hätte auch das Schloss gegeben.
Ich wäre sicherer, wenn du den Schlüssel runterschluckst, aber das ist nicht möglich, weil du vorher eher das machen musst. Ich mache auch die Augen zu. Ich mache immer die Augen zu, die Ohren zu, alles sicher zu. Neulich habe ich mit einem Kumpel geskypt und der hatte so ein neues Schlosslich gekauft, den ich fürs Fahrrad und hat während er mit mir gesprochen hat, so daran rumgespielt und ein neues Zahlencode-Ding eingeloggt. Au! Und dann wieder rumgespielt und es war, er kann sich das einfach wegwerfen. Und er kann sich nicht daran erinnern? Nein, nein, nein, nein, es war ja so Übersprungshandlung, er hat daran gedreht und dann muss man so einen Knopf drücken, dann lockt man das neue ein, als das ist jetzt die neue Zahlencode, aber es hat nur drei so Drehdinger. Und ich denke mir, klar, als Dieb auf der Strasse hast du jetzt nicht Zeit, die ganzen 999 Zahlen durchzugehen. Das sind Tausend, ein kleiner Gag hier vorne. Aber wenn du ... Du hast die Null auch noch. Nee, nee, ganz kurz, nicht das, nicht das, weil das stimmt nicht, ich stimme nicht. Wenn ihr klatscht habt ihr, nein,, nein, nein, nein, ich stimme einfach nicht. Man vergisst immer die Null nicht, das war's, danke, tschau Leute, mach's gut. So, ich stimme nicht. Ja, aber glaubst du... Nein, nein, nein, du kommst jetzt nicht raus. Doch. Drei, drei mal neun. Ja, und die Null. Ja, die Null ja auch. Also tausend insgesamt. Ja, gut. Aber glaubst du nicht, ja. Das stimmt. Aber nicht zehntausend, was er ursprünglich gesagt hat, wofür er geklatscht hat. Nein, aber jetzt, wenn ich eines weiß, dann, dass solche Zahlenkombinationen, die man so nebenbei reinmacht, nicht zufällig sind. Okay, Psychoanalytiker. Ja, mit Ernst, ja, gut, Hypnose ist einfach wissenschaftlich bewiesen, sorry, ist einfach so. Ja, probieren Sie mal 420. Ja, zum Beispiel. So läuft für dich eine Psychoanalyse ab, oder was? Nee, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich glaube wirklich, dass wenn du mit ihm eine Hypnose machst oder so eine Rückführung, als er Napoleon war oder Kleopatra oder so, dass dann irgendwann diese Zahlenkombination auftaucht. Ich würde das echt nicht aufgeben, weil diese Zahl, egal welche Zahl das jetzt ist, das hat eine Bewandtnis. Aber Frage, dauert es nicht länger, diese Hypnose, diesen Hypnotisier zu googeln erstmal? Gut, dass Sie fragen, Herr Tietze, mittlerweile auf dem Markt auch die Fünf-Minuten-Hypnose für jeden Zuhause anwendbar, überhaupt kein Problem. Okay, Teleshopping, ich will es sehen. Kennen Sie das auch? Sie wollen sich hypnotisieren und haben nicht den ganzen Nachmittag Zeit? Ja, ihr sitzt zu Hause vom Fernsehen, ihr könnt sagen, was ihr wollt, das ist mir egal. Hier zum Beispiel der Stefan. Nein, alle wollen den Neisser-Deisser sehen, niemand will, es ist Hypnose-Scheisse. Stefan, das ist unser Praktikant Stefan hier, der hat sich bereit erklärt. Stefan, du hast massive unbewusste Probleme, die wir heute versuchen rauszuholen. Ja, ich habe sehr viele Schlösser in meiner Wohnung unbrauchbar gemacht. Okay, und Praktikant Stefan hat uns auch noch gesagt. Warum sagen Sie immer Praktikant davor? Das haben wir alle beim ersten. Du bist so süß. Und er hat uns auch gesagt, dass er ein Schlossig gekauft hat, weil er sein Fahrrad, das nicht mehr als 50 Euro wert ist, unbedingt absperren wollte. Weil es unbezahltes Praktikum ist. Genau. Wir bezahlen mit Erfahrung, das ist unendlich viel wert. Und da hast du drei Zahlen eingespeichert, und die möchtest du jetzt wieder rausholen. Ja, sehr gerne, ja. Alles klar. Gut, deswegen haben wir hier die fünf Minuten Hypnose. Ist eine Creme? Es ist immer eine Creme. Why? Wenn ich jetzt mein Shirt aussehen muss, wieder dann. Einmal reichlich auf die Hand drücken, reichlich und dann einmal übers Gesicht steht alles im Vertrag, Stefan. Ich weiß, das ist der Grund, warum ich mich nicht wehr. Im Vertrag und du schläfst ein. Stefan, erinnere dich in deiner Kindheit.
Du kamst in das Zimmer deiner Mutter. Sie war unter ihrer Bettdecke, rot im Gesicht, du wusstest, was sie tat mit ihrer Hand unter der Bettdecke. Nein, so ein Scheiss ist das einfach normalerweise. Du hörst die Kuckucksuhr, bing bong, bing bong, wie viel Uhr schlug die Uhr in dieser Sekunde? Sieben, sieben. Erinner dich zurück, dein erster Tag in der Schule, Biologie, Sexualkunde, wie entsteht neues Leben? Plötzlich, als du das Buch aufgeschlagen hast, es kribbelte in deinem Schritt und plötzlich hattest du den Drang, deine Unterhose zu wechseln. Auf welcher Seite war das Bild? 69. 69, Stefan, du bist wach! Hol das Schloss. Kannst du dich an irgendwas erinnern? Nein. Gib in das Schloss jetzt ein. Nur eine Berührung in meinem Schrittregion. Gib in das Schloss jetzt ein. Okay. Sieben, sechs, neun. Und das Schloss ist offenbar in der Arm und der 19,99 Euro im Teleshop, ab jetzt verfügbar. Vielen Dank an Stefan, grossen Applaus. Stefan, nicht mehr Praktikant Stefan. Ja, für Stefan, unser Volontär Stefan. Nein! Na also, Rede, Rede, Rede, Rede. Was ist das für eine Show? Rede, ich sag jetzt gar nichts. Jesus. Ja, okay, sorry Zuschauer, ich weiss, dass ihr andere Produkte kaufen wollt, aber ich bin jetzt hier gerade befördert worden. Ja, vielen Dank an meinen Boss, ich war jetzt seit sieben Jahren unbezahlter Praktikant und mir wurde immer gesagt, dass ich hier meine Chancen, meinen Weg gehen kann. Ich habe schon daran gezweifelt, wirklich. Aber ja, ich wollte dann auch mit meiner Mutter darüber reden, ob ich vielleicht den Job wechseln muss, aber ich habe sie über was unschämt erwischt. Deswegen konnte ich das Gespräch nicht mit dir. Bravo, alles klar, Dankeschön, das war unser neuer Volontär Stefan, vielen Dank. Volontär. Dankeschön, tschüss. Auch gut, dass das... Tschüss. Die Karriere ist nicht steil, die Karriere ist aufsteigend, aber sie ist so.
Ja, sie ist langsam, wie eine Sprungschanze. Aber das ist es, ich glaube, dein Freund.
Bitte was? Wie eine Sprungschanze.
Sie ist langsam wie eine Sprungschanze.
Ja, das hat man mir damals gesagt, als ich in meinem allerersten Job im Callcenter gesagt habe, kann ich meine Gehaltserhöhung haben.
Und ich glaube, ich habe irgendwie von 10 Euro in die Stunde auf 10,20 Euro oder irgendwie so ein Bullshit. Das sind wie viel Prozent? 0,2. 0,2, okay, alles klar, gut. Dafür gibt es Radierer, mein Lieber, man kann sich auch irren im Leben. Oder Tintenkiller. Und dann habe ich auch gesagt, es ist aber ein bisschen wenig und und dann hat mein Chef damals auch gesagt, es ist eine Rampe. Man fängt langsam an, aber dann geht es steil nach oben. Ein halbes Jahr später habe ich gekündigt. Nie irgendwie höher geworden. Es ist eine Rampe. Es ist eine Rampe, ja. Du kannst immer sagen, wenn die Erwachsen... Aber es gibt auch so eine Rampe. Nein, das ist schon, Rampen fangen erstmal langsam an und dann eine Rollstuhlrampe, hoffentlich nicht zum Beispiel.
Also es wäre so weird, wenn die jetzt sehr leicht...
Ich rufe jetzt meinen Chef an, du hast fucking recht, der schuldet mir Geld.
Ruf den an.
Der schuldet mir fucking Geld.
Ruf den jetzt mal an.
Okay.
Ich halte mich hier zurück.
Das war...
Ich habe die Nummer tatsächlich.
Ja, Kurswahl wahrscheinlich.
0800 Chef.
Okay. Meierling? Hallo? Hallo, ja, guten Tag. Ja, wer spricht denn da? Ja, hier ist Florentin, damals aus dem Callcenter. Ist es ein Callcenter? Nee, dann will ich nichts mit diesem Unfug zu tun haben. Nein, Entschuldigung, ich meine natürlich die Wellnessanstalt, die Sie damals betrieben haben. Ah, okay. Genau, Sie haben damals gesagt, dass die Gehaltserhöhung von 10 Euro auf 10,20 Euro, dass es eine Rampe war. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht an alles erinnern. Haben Sie schon mal an Rollstuhlrampen gedacht? Wie gesagt, ich kann mich jetzt nicht an alles erinnern, was ich will. Ich will das Geld bis morgen Mittag. Tschüss.
Einfach mal eine Ansage machen.
Wir treffen uns an der Telefonzelle.
Entschuldigung, das habe ich vergessen.
An der 33. 23rd Street.
So viel cooler auf Englisch.
An der alten Mühle.
Das ist das deutsche Ecke, 42nd Street.
Ja, es gab bei uns tatsächlich eine alte Mühle. Bei uns auch. Ja, es gab eine alte Mühle. Die gab es wirklich. Nie Schlägerei gehabt. Nie eine Schlägerei da gehabt. Einmal wurde da ein Zigarettenautomat versenkt, aber das war's. Versenkt? Ja. Reingeworfen? Ja, bei uns wurde irgendwie halbstark ein Zigarettenautomat geklaut und dann nicht aufbekommen. Und dann wohin mit diesem belastenden Beweismaterial? Ja, ja, genau. Wo die ganzen Fingerabdrücke drauf sind. Ja, und die erbärmlichen Versuche, mit irgendwie einem Löffel oder so das Ding aufzubrechen, oder wie man sich das als 16-Jähriger vorstellt. Du weißt sehr viel über den Tathergang. Bitte frag mich nicht, ob ich es geklaut habe. Nee, nee, aber ich meine, Zigarettenautomat, niemand hier verdächtigt dich. Nein! Niemand hier denkt, dass Florentin ein Zigarettenautomat aufgemacht hätte. Nein! Aber ich meine, du weißt trotzdem sehr viel. Genau, alles klar. Ich muss ganz kurz noch mal, ich habe leider was in meinem Auto vergessen, sorry. Ich habe leider was Wichtiges, ich komme gleich wieder. Oder warst du damals in diesem Team, was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass Florentin damals, dass du so von der Polizei so als Spitzel, damit die Polizei erfährt, so wie Randall, wie heißt der bei den Simpsons? Randall, Randall. Ja, der. Das ist so wie, das ist so wie... Sehr stille Simpsons-Ecke hier vorne, aber gut, okay, kein Problem. Stimmt's. Kein Problem, hohe Frisuren, aber sehr still heute Abend. Aber das ist so von der Polizei, von der örtlichen Polizei so als der ausgemacht wurde, der sehr viel über die Mitte wieder lästert und so. Da hast du meine Jugend perfekt zusammengepasst. An der Coverkind, wie geil! Wenn es einen Direktorspitzel geben würde, wäre ich das auf jeden Fall gewesen. Ich war sogar tatsächlich in der Schule so eine Art Lehrer. Das ist wenig Sinn, aber wir hatten so ein Programm, weil unsere Schule hatte zu wenig Lehrer und hat gesagt, ja, Moment mal, aber können nicht die, denen wir Sachen beibringen, das wiederum anderen beibringen? Geniale Idee. Ja, wie so eine Sektpyramide. Du musst es ja oben nur einmal reinkippen. Es ist ein Pyramid-Scheme, reingenommen. Die machen das ja von alleine. Der Sekt schmeckt ja unten auch noch gut. Oder? Ich weiß es nicht. Ja, warum nicht? Ich habe so ein Ding weder gesehen, noch trinke ich Sekt, aber ich denke mal, das ist auch lecker.
Aber du würdest es nicht von unten nehmen.
Nur falls du mal in eine Situation kommst, wo du an eine Sektpyramide geführt wirst.
Und du darfst jetzt nicht das Sektglas nehmen.
Ja, aber ich kann ja nicht von ganz oben nehmen.
Wo ist der?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Weil wenn es eine Pyramide ist, hat es ja auch eine Ausdehnung von, also Basisfläche zu Spitzenhöhe.
Ja, was Pi? Gut, Pi zählt drei Pi. So, und dann kann ich ja mit meinem Arm... In Pi sind ja alle Zahlen drin, also insofern war das nicht so falsch. Und dann bin ich in einem Programm beigetreten, das hieß Schüler, Lehren, Schüler. In Klammern, it's not a pyramid scheme. Don't sue us, tm. Ja, es ist also ein Schüler, Lehren, Schüler, Lehren,, Schülerlernen, Schüler, so ein Kreis. Ja, ja, genau. This is not a triangle, it's a circle. Es war offensichtlich eine Pyramide, aber sie haben einen Kreis drum gemalt, was dann wirklich aussah wie … Ja, genau. Es ist ein Kegelschema, kein Problem, ist nicht verboten. Und es sah dann auch wie das Harry Potter, Deathly Hallows Zeichen. Ja, ja, genau. It's not a pyramid scheme. Nein, nein. Und das habe ich dann gemacht und habe Kindern Sachen beigebracht, die ich selber nicht verstanden habe. Wie, ehrlich jetzt? Ja, wirklich. Wo hast du das Selbstbewusstsein? Ich war dann irgendwie so in der neunten Klasse und sollte den fünf Klässlern was beibringen, wo ich auch dachte, ist das genug Abstand? Ist das genug Abstand? Ist das genug Abstand? Ist vier Jahre die magische Zahl, wo man Leuten was beibringen kann? Das sind vier Jahre für dich? Naja, wie lang ist so ein Leben? Mach mal, wie lang ist so ein Leben? So lang? Nein, Leben ist, nein, hör auf, Leben ist viel länger. Leben ist viel länger. Nee, komm, komm, komm, jetzt mal ohne Busunfall, jetzt mal weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, ohne Rauchen, ohne Alkohol, oh, okay, Botschaft. Und hier sind die vier Jahre gut aufgehoben, finde ich. Ich konnte dir nichts beibringen. Ich habe den Tisch in das Spiel beigebracht, das war natürlich eine andere Art.
Ich meine, ich habe in denen natürlich Potenzial gesehen. Ich habe gesehen, Englisch ist nicht deren Stärke, aber die haben eine Vorhand, meine Herren. Und dann musst du natürlich auch gucken, ein guter Lehrer weiß ja, wie man die Leute, also kann ja die Potenziale fördern, darum geht's ja. Und ich habe gesagt, eure Potenziale sind nicht in dem Klassenraum. Das ist auch wie Pokémon-Trainer eigentlich, ne? Eigentlich so, ich bin mir vor, dass du eine Klasse und dann tritt dir so einen anderen, so einen Sport oder so, gegen andere Klassen an, dann hast du wie so kleine Versionen, wie so kleine Pokémons, die dann gegeneinander antreten. Du machst dir so ein Team aus sechs und dann so, los, jetzt du,
so, und jetzt Tackle, Rebecca.
Yes, Algebra.
Fehlgeschlagen. Bände an.
Ruckzuckhieb auf Martin.
Ja, Ruckzuckhieb können alle. Martin weint.
Martin ist paralysiert.
Martin ist sowas von paralysiert.
Martin muss die Rampe hochfahren.
Laura schläft.
Laura kämpft doch gar nicht.
Laura schläft. Nina hat ihre
Vielen Dank. Martin ist sowas von paralysiert, Martin muss die Rampe hochfahren. Laura schläft, Laura kämpft doch gar nicht. Laura schläft, Nina hat ihre Tage und ist deswegen vom Pokémon-Training ausgeschlossen. Befreit. Befreit, ja, gut, dass du es sagst. Ich will das nicht ausschliessen, deswegen, sie, vielleicht hat sie die auch gar nicht, aber sie hat sich vorgetäuscht, weil sie nicht beim Pokémon-Training teilnehmen wollte wollte. Ja, ja. Weiß es nicht. Ich versuche immer in Bewegung zu bleiben in letzter Zeit. Ich habe das Gefühl, dadurch kann man, ich habe heute auch eine Tüte Chips gegessen und ich habe mich schlecht gefühlt, weil ich mir dachte, da ist so viel, da könnte man Marathon laufen von den Kalorien in dieser Tüte Chips. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich kann ja einfach während ich die Tüte Chips esse tanzen. Also einfach, aber jetzt, also, jetzt tanzen ich nicht jetzt irgendwie Detlef-Di-Soest mässig, sondern halt so dieser lockere Schritt, einfach so, dieser Basisschritt. Also standst du heute in dem Hotelzimmer neben mir, warst du den ganzen Tag so und hast die Chips reingeballert. Ja, und ich dachte mir so, wenn du während dem Chips essen tanzt, wird die Kalorien sofort verbrannt und das ist Grunde. Und es hat einfach Ist das, wie du tanzt eigentlich im echten Leben? Nee, nee, normalerweise. So, und jetzt müsst ihr richtig ausrasten, damit die Podcast-Hörer denken, dass es richtig krass ist, einfach Wow! Nein! Das glaube ich nicht! Das ist immer wichtig. Das glaube ich nicht. Immer die Raupe. Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, eure Schultern sind eine Raupe, die über die Tanzfläche raupen. Und so kommt die überall hin. Zum Ausgang. Ich bin raus, Leute. Es ist halb zehn, in halb zehn lege ich im Bett. Und wichtig ist, die Jacke immer in der Hand zu haben. Ja, genau. Ich würde gerne tanzen lernen. Gibt es einen Tanzstil, wo man irgendwie einfach auch den Rucksack noch anhalten kann und die Jacke so über der Schulter oder so? Ja, sicherlich, also wir können auch einfach eine Samba oder eine Rumba so tanzen. Ja, wirklich? Ja. Okay. Also, ich weiß nicht, also wir hier alle im Tanzkurs legen unsere Sachen lieber ab und haben auch keine Jacke an, aber wenn Sie das wollen, ist das okay. Ich versuche einen Tanz, der einfach direkt auf den Ausgang tanzt, einfach egal aus welcher Position, direkt auf den Ausgang. Ja, aber das bieten wir jetzt eigentlich nicht an. Also, wieso wollen Sie denn so gerne gehen? Wieso wollen Sie denn schon gehen? Sie machen ja diesen Sambaschritt immer nach vorne und nach hinten. Ja, genau. Kann man den nicht adaptieren, dass man einfach so, so, oh Leute, ciao, ich kann nicht anders, toll, der Rhythmus, die Musik treibt mich an. Und die Tanzpartnerin wird so mitgezogen, so, ich will eigentlich noch bleiben. Ja, ja, die Musik treibt mich an. Ich habe mich so nett mit Bernhard unterhalten.
Ist leider, ciao Leute, ich bin raus, macht's gut,
ich komme hier nie wieder hoch.
Bleib mal da unten, frag mal, woher die Leute so kommen. Hey, woher
kommt ihr? Ich bin mir nochmal bei dir, du hast dich eh schon.
Podcast, ähm,
du kommst aus dem Podcast?
Komm mal, ein Podcast, wir auch.
Podcast, äh, Talentscout.
Oh, okay, ein Podcast, Talentsc Scout. Ist dir heute Abend jemand aufgefallen? Ich selbst. Okay, sieht schlecht aus, leider. Schade. Halt die Augen offen auf jeden Fall. Achtung. Aber du hast doch gesehen, dass ich was ...
So, sehr gut gemacht. Nice. Entschuldigung, das war, oh, oh, der ist überhaupt nicht, oh, da guckt jemand richtig böse am Ton. Das tut mir richtig leid. Entschuldigung. Aber an alle Akrobatik-Talentscouts... Aber wie gemein, du hast doch gesehen, dass ich getrunken habe. Ich habe es nicht gesehen, tut mir leid. Wie so ein... Es ist so gemein, so Arbeitsmobbing, es ist immer so Bullying am Arbeitsplatz. Warum hast du genau in dem Moment die Flasche aufgemacht?
Nein, nein, nein, ich hätte die in der Hand. Warum wirbst du das Mikrofon auf mich? Wie kannst du das jetzt umdrehen? Ach, es tut mir leid. Du bist kein guter Wingman, muss man sagen. Du bist einfach immer zu viel Sache in der Hand, immer nicht da. Ja, es ist auch, stell dir mal vor, ich wäre jetzt hier für so eine Party gewesen und ich habe gerade so meinen Crush angesprochen und so, hey, was geht und du so aus dem Nichts irgendwas. Ja, da musst du bereit sein. Ich habe in die Flasche gesprochen. Ich habe in die Flasche gesprochen. Kein Scheiss. Wir gucken den Playback an. Trottel. Wir haben ein Safeword tatsächlich eingebaut in unsere Sendung. Wir verraten aber nicht, was es ist und wofür es steht. Ich habe es vergessen. Ich hoffe, nicht wirklich. Wir haben ein Safe-Word eingebaut und das könnten wir noch ein zweites Safe-Word einbauen, weil du wieder in dein Wasser redest. Ich muss dann immer das Safe-Word, wenn ich was trinke, anmelden vorher. Safe-Wort ist Poseidon.
Wow, da kommt niemand drauf.
In diesem Sinne Poseidon.
Ich glaube, ich kriege das hin, Poseidon in den Satz einzubauen, wenn es sein muss, wenn du wieder in die Flasche redest.
Okay, dann bitte. Wir sind bei einem Bewerbungsgespräch für ein BND.
Okay. Wobei, wenn man irgendwo Poseidon einbauen kann, dann in diesem sehr merkwürdigen Setting, was ich gerade vorgeschlagen habe. Ja. Vielleicht machen wir lieber Controlling. Okay, was auch immer das ist. Bewerbung für einen langweiligen Controlling-Job. Sie müssen halt viel mit Zahlen machen, haben Sie damit Erfahrung? Ach so, ja, also ich beherrsche das Meer der Zahlen so gut wie Neptun sein Meer. Warum hast du jetzt Neptun gesagt? Warum machst du dir die Aufgabe noch schwieriger? Warum sagst du nicht direkt Poseidon? Naja, ich dachte, sie stellt mir die Frage, wo ich mich in fünf Jahren sehe, denn in fünf Jahren könnte ich durchaus auf dem Level eines Poseidon sein. Denn wir alle wissen, Poseidon ist mächtiger als Neptun. Haut ab, Römer, haut ab, Römer, die Römer-Fraktion, ich sehe euch schon an. Warum ist es gerankt und wo ist Aquaman in dieser Liste? Oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Ist der ein Sohn von irgendeinem? Ich glaube schon, oder? Nee, nee, Aguament ist doch einfach eins zu eins. Nee. Neptun. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich mit Superhelden überhaupt nicht aus. Mit Michael Phelps? Nee, ich habe jetzt so einen Mann mit so zwei Delfinköpfen als Armen vor Augen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie der aussieht. Das ist Michael Phelps. Ich glaube, Florian weiss wirklich nicht, wer das ist. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Olympischer Schwimmer. Ach so. Ah, okay. Alles klar. Ah, okay. Okay, alles klar. Stimmt die Geschichte, dass er eines Tages ausgerutscht ist, in den See gefallen ist und versucht hat, sich über Wasser zu halten und dann jemand zu ihm kam und sagte, Sie werden Gold holen. Sie werden eines Tages Gold holen. Und dann hat er nicht geholfen, das ist gegangen. Nee, muss man auch nicht. Man muss die Leute fordern und fördern. Bist du mal eingebrochen in dem See? Auf dem Eis oder so? Einbrich. Das ist eine typische Frage. Am Rande, ich bin am Rande eingebrochen. Bei uns war das irgendwie so, wir hatten so ein Dorfsee. Ich bin am Rande eingebrochen, also so wie fast. Also rein juristisch ist das noch nicht verjährt, deswegen muss ich mich wagehalten. Aber da war immer so das, na ja klar, der See ist in der Mitte am dicksten. Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment. Die Eisfläche? Ja, und ich dachte mir, okay, ich bin kein so skeptisches Kind. Also bist du Anlauf genommen und bist in die Mitte des Sees geschwunden. Und dann mein Bruder und ich mit unseren Eishockey-Stielen so, ja, am Anfang bricht man so ein bisschen ein am Ufer und ich so, okay, Bruder, krrr. Am Anfang ist das Eis ein bisschen schwach, lass uns komplett rübergehen, lass uns all in gehen und da rein, wo wir nicht mehr schwimmen können, stehen können. Und irgendwann wurde es dicker und ich habe das einfach akzeptiert, okay, so ist die Welt einfach. Und dein Bruder hat es überlebt? Nein, leider nicht. Tut mir leid, er war leider sehr klein, so dass er auch am Ufer einfach direkt ertrunken ist. Das ist leider ganz unglücklich gewesen, ganz unglücklich. Ich will seit gestern will ich Kinder haben, weil uns wurde ein Video geschickt vom Kindergeburtstag, weil wir sind Dino-Fans, grosse Dino-Fans. Ja, noch ein bisschen noch. In einer letzten Folge haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass der Tyrannosaurus Rex inzwischen wieder ein Monster wird, ein bisschen. Wir arbeiten hart daran an dem Image und es wurde eine Kindergeburtstagsfeier gezeigt, wo der Vater dann eben drüber geschrieben hat, ja, wir haben einen Tyrannosaurus Rex geheiert für unseren Kindergeburtstag.
Es war einfach ein sehr, sehr gutes Kostüm eines Tyrannosaurus Rex. Also ist ein Mann gekommen, plötzlich ist es diese Kindergeburtstagsfeier, die in so einem, ich weiß nicht, in so einem klimischen Kindergeburtstagsort, es gab auch eine Hüpfburg und so was, es waren so Getränke aufgebaut und es waren ganz viele Kinder. Keine Gefahr in Sicht, man fühlt sich wohl, man fühlt sich sicher. Plötzlich aus dem Nichts ist die Tür aufgegangen, so ein riesen Dino in einem sehr guten Kostüm mit so richtigen Gummizähnen, also richtig crazy gut ist dann da reingelaufen und die Kinder sind durchgedreht im negativen Sinne. Todesangst.
Also es ist so ein tolles Video und genau das, deswegen will ich Kinder haben, weil diese Geburtsfeier, ich finde die so toll und dann ist es so hart geschnitten, es ist nicht so gut geschnittenitten, es ist auf dem Amateurvideo, aber es gibt so einen Cut, aber die Schreie reissen nicht ab, es ist so ein, und die flippen das nicht, die können auch nicht abstrahieren, dass es gerade kein Dinosaurier ist, und die sehr viele clevere Kinder fliehen in die Hüpfburg, weil die ist so abgezäunt, gleich mit so einem, weiß ich nicht, so einem Netz, aber ein Kind im Hintergrund, ich habe es sehr oft geguckt und ich glaube, du auch, aber ein Kind im Hintergrund läuft so mega panisch, weiss nicht, was es machen soll, und läuft auf eine Couch zu und geht auf die Couch und das Ding und der Typ im Diokostüm auch so, erst mal, was hat er für einen Job? Was hat er für einen fucking geilen Job? Und er denkt auch so, ja, ich werde nicht weiterhin so tun, als würde ich dich fressen. Aber das Kind ist auf eine Couch gegangen. Why? Es bringt nichts. Weil das Kind ist so gross und dann ist es so gross. Das Maul ist auch noch auf der Höhe. Also es hat alles schlechter gemacht. Ja, du bittest sie direkt den Kopf auf Maulhöhe. Ja, genau. Dann nehme ich sie ab ganz. Timmy will sterben wie ein Held. Und die Kinder in der Hüpfburg haben sich sicher gefühlt, bis der Kopf durch den Eingang der Hüpfburg rein und kläffend und die Kinder sich versucht haben, an der Wand zu kreffen. Es gab so kurze Moment, wo die dachten so okay, this was a great idea und stand dann alle so und so. Ein paar haben schon wieder so ein bisschen gegrinst und so und dann steckt dann die Koffe durch und jeder loost es wieder. Es ist so ein neues Video. Ich glaube, ich würde mich nicht interessieren, glauben die Kinder wirklich, dass das ein Dinosaurier ist oder nicht?
Weil es ist ja, also wenn die wirklich panisch weglaufen, schreien, die müssen das, vor allem als Eltern kannst du ja machen, was du willst, es ist ja nicht so, als ob man sich danach bei seinem Kind entschuldigt oder so. Aber es war das Kind völlig außer Atem, in Tränen, liegt auf dem Boden und so, so Ralf, wir gehen jetzt, ne, ciao. Ja, ja.
Einfach ist ja nicht so, du, Ralf, ey, sorry, Entschuldigung, Ralf, ey, sorry, wir haben da richtig Scheiße gebaut. Ralf, das war... Diese Augen! Ja, ja, die Planung, ey, die Planung war schlecht, der Typ war viel zu aggressiv, wir wussten nicht, dass er vorbestraft war, sorry. Wir hatten uns eher so ein lustiges Tabaluga-Kostüm vorgestellt. Kannst du mir verzeihen, mein Sohn? Ja, Mama. Okay. Du fucking Psychopath-Mutter. Ja, Jesus. Aber es war so ein gutes Video, wirklich. Also deswegen Kinder zu haben, allein um die so zu traumatisieren, auf diese Art. Ja, wirklich. Aber in welchem Punkt dachte der Mann, es wäre eine gute Idee, oder die Frau, diesen Dinosaurier zu engagieren? Das ist fantastisch. Aber der Typ hat den besten Job der Welt, ne? Also wirklich, du hast einfach dieses Dinosaurierkostüm geklaut offensichtlich, ich weiß nicht, wo man das kaufen kann, irgendwo gefunden oder geklaut, gebaut, und dann kannst du den ganzen Tag Kinder erstrecken. Das ist grossartig. Ich fand das so fantastisch. Wahnsinn. Und dann aber auch ein paar Eltern waren auch dabei, die irgendwann so aus dem Wege gegangen sind, augenweit aufgerissen und so. Der hat der Spaß wirklich auf. Ja. Und dann lief der so vorbei. Also die waren auch, es waren nicht alle Eltern, so mega Party-Time, es ist eine gute Idee. Aber es ist auch zu leicht, Kinder zu erschrecken. Ich habe ja meinen Zivildienst mit Kindern gemacht und dann gab es manchmal so Gerüchte, so Gerüchte von so gewissen Monstern oder Gefahren und ich hatte so vier verschiedene Zivildienststellen mit vier Kindergruppen in vier Orten. Zahl vier spielt eine grosse Rolle in dieser Geschichte. Ja, absolut, merkt euch das, am Ende sind es vier Monster, die sich zusammenschliessen. Und man konnte immer so nachverfolgen und dann gab es dann immer so, und dann eines Tages hieß es so, du, wir wollen heute nicht raus, wir haben Angst vor dem Kuhmann.
Ich habe mir so, Kuhmann, ja, der Kuhmann, der geht rum und der nimmt die Kinder mit.
Und dann, ja und dann, was, wo, was, welches Motiv, Schatz, welches Motiv?
Eines, komm, eins, gib mir eine realistische Geschichte. Aber Kuhmann im Sinne von Milchkuhmann oder Kuhmann? Ja, Milchkuhmann. Nein, das Tier Kuh. Du meinst der Buchstabe Kuh? Kuhmann. Kuhmann. Und er zwingt die Kinder, durch ihn durchzuspringen. Ja, ich wäre wieder in die Pädophilie-Richtung gegangen, es ist ein grosser... Nein, ja, ja, okay. Er zwingt uns, Wörter zu bilden mit Q am Anfang. Ich weiß nicht. Und es gibt nur Qualle und Qual. Es gibt nur Qualle, sagt die Nina immer schon. Und es ist einfach so, der einzige Instinkt ist, das fucking lameste Monster, das ich je gehört habe. Es gibt viel schlimmere Dinge da draußen, mein Gott. Aber du musst es halt ernst nehmen, so einstet ihr. Und was war denn dann der Kuhmann? Gab es denn nicht? Keine Ahnung. Niemand weiß, wo solche Geschichten seinen Anfang nehmen, ob irgendjemand sich das ausdenkt oder es einfach ein Fehler war zu hören. Aber es gibt doch zumindest, also bei uns in der Grundschule wurde irgendwie so ein grosser Milchkarton vorher hingestellt. Jeder könnt sich Vanillemilch, Schoko und so aussuchen und Erdbeermilch. Der Mann, der das bringt, den hätte ich gefragt. Ja, das stimmt. Oh ja, gut, das ist ein geiler Horrorfilm eigentlich, ne? Die Kinder, ja, ne, ach komm. Okay, Pitch einfach sofort. Irgendwie die Kinder erzählen davon und der Erzieher sagt am Anfang, ne, das ist kein Ding und so, und dann merkt er aber, dass der Milchmann hat so Blut an der Hand oder so, oder Blut am Bund. Okay, wir gehen direkt all in mit Blut. Blut aus dem Ohr oder so ein Ding, keine Ahnung, nee, genau, Achtung, das Kind sagt eines Tages, oh, der Kuhmann, der Kuhmann, der hat nur vier Finger an einer Hand oder so, und dann sagt er, ah, kein Problem, ist kein Ding. Und eines Tages dann so, ah, die Milchrechnung so, ich muss die Milchrechnung zahlen. Und er sieht, der Milchmann hat Blut an der Hand. Ach so. Und dann denkt er, holy ship, vielleicht ist es er, aber es ist nicht. Und dann die vier Kuhmänner. Und ja, und vor allem, also, es ist aber ein guter Impuls, weil es ist ja oft so, dass solche Kindermonster gewisse Lektionen haben. Also du hast ja dann tatsächlich so zum Beispiel irgendeinen böser Rabe gibt es als Kindersage. Vielleicht ist Kuhmann sowas für laktoseintolerante Kinder. Ja, genau. Du hast so einen Rabe, der immer nachts ist, damit die Kinder nicht nachts rausgehen. Oder so ein Wassermonster, damit die Kinder nicht ins Wasser gehen. Früher hatten Familien halt irgendwie zwölf Kinder und da kannst kannst du dich nicht um jedes kümmern, und dann erzählst du ihnen halt die Geschichte.
Aber ist auch nicht so schlimm, wenn drei schreit.
Ja, genau. Und du denkst ja gut, wenn drei an Kuhmann…
Milchmärchenrechnung.
Und ich hab halt gedacht, der Kuhmann ist so lame, dass ich halt,
und das war vielleicht rückblicklich nicht so klug,
ich halt die Geschichte cooler nacherzählt,
auch an anderen Kindern.
Du hast ihn böser gemacht.
Und ich hab daraus gemacht, weil ich fand es viel cooler,
anstatt ein, weil ich dachte, das ist ein Mann, der trägt einen Kuhkopf auf dem Kopf. Jesus Christ. Weil ich dachte, das ist viel cooler als Bild, anstatt, weil die haben, die sind halt super schlecht in Charakterdesign und so. Ich habe denen gesagt, Kuhmann, wie sieht der aus und so, ja, das ist halb Kuh, halb Mensch, wo ist der Schnittpunkt, wo Oberkörper, Kuh, Unterkörper, Mensch, anders so. Oder so ganz oft geteilt. Ja, genau. Das finde ich nämlich doof, wie so ein Zebrastreifen. Ja, das finde ich so doof in der Fantasywelt, das ist immer so, es ist immer quer oder so, aber es ist nie zu Zebramäßig, dass es sich andauernd abwechselt. Ja, so Schichten. Und dann haben die auch gesagt, ja, weiß ich nicht genau, aber rückblickend war das total gut, um denen die Angst zu nehmen, weil sie sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung, weil das so nicht so, ja, wo fängt das an, existiert nicht, und ich habe es dann aber cooler nacherzählt. Wem? Anderen Kindern? Der anderen Gruppe. Der anderen Gruppe, damit die Angst ist. Wir wollen nicht raus, der Kuhmann, ich so, ja, Kuhmann, habe ich gehört, der trägt ja so einen Kuhkopf auf, ich fand das so cool. Auch super unrealistisch, die Kinder hätten nur die Frage stellen müssen, wie sieht der durch die Schnauze und ich wäre blank gewesen, hätte nichts gehabt, hätte gesagt, Leute, ich bin raus, ihr habt mich. Haben sie nicht gemacht, zu viel Angst. Aber du hast dann eine Gruppe gehabt als Erzieher? Vier. Das sollte also... Das hätte ankommen sollen. Ich schreibe es einfach mal auf, die vier. Ich schreibe es nochmal auf, ja. Ich schreibe es mal auf, einfach, dass wir uns das merken, das ist die Zahl des heutigen Abends. Ich hätte nämlich dann, ich glaube zwei Kindergärtnerinnen waren für meine Gruppe zuständig.
Ja, so ungefähr war das auch, ja.
Du hast gerade vier Gruppen gehabt.
Genau, vier Gruppen.
Sehr viele Kinder.
Können Sie mal kurz durchrechnen? Vier Gruppen, zwei Erzieher pro Gruppe.
Du hast gerade gesagt, du warst Erzieher für vier Gruppen.
Ja, ich bin ja immer nur Zivi, ich war nur der Trottel, der die Lampen anzieht und die Kinder terrorisiert. Das war ja meine Aufgabe. Der Typ, der sich wieder diese Kuhmann-Geschichte anhören kann, weil die Frauen keine Bock mehr drauf haben. Ich frage mich, ob es das heute auch noch gibt. Ich weiß nicht, kommt jemand aus dem Bereich Rosenheim-Kreis Ebersberg oder irgendwie sowas, ob es die Geschichte noch gibt? Vielleicht habe ich irgendwie sowas in Gang gesetzt. Der Kuhmann, das raunt man sich heute noch so zu und alle fragen sich, wo kommt das her. Eine geile True Crime-Dokumentary. Ja, Kuhcrime. Leute, macht's gut. Ciao, wir sind raus. Kuhcrime. Oder Muckrime. Kann man viel machen mit Kuhn. Es geht alles. Muckrime. Die Kuh reimt sich auf das, was sie sagt. Das ist schon abgefahren. Das ist wie Pokémon. Bleibt halt ein bisschen lame, wäre ich gesagt. Es ist wie Pokémon, ja. Das ist wie wenn Katzen Kiau heißen würden, oder irgendwie sowas. Einfach super faul. Ich hatte auch eine Erinnerung, die habe ich noch sehr doll im Kopf, wie ich mal auf so eine Rutsche gegangen bin, als Kind, und die war oben so ein Maul. Ich glaube, die gibt es häufiger, aber es ist so ein Drache. Und da, weil du gerade meintest, checken die Kinder, dass es kein T-Rex ist, ich glaube, die checken das. Ich habe auch gewusst, dass es eine fucking Rutsche ist, die mich jetzt nicht isst. Und die Rutsche war die Zunge, oder was? Weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Oben gab es auf jeden Fall so einen, so einen grossen, also man musste so reinklettern und im richtigen Moment rein, weil sonst geht so ein Maul zu, und dann rutscht man hinten, glaube ich, wieder raus. Und da habe ich ja auch gewusst, das ist jetzt kein Dinosaurier, kein echter, wo ich dann hochkletter.
Aber es klingt wahnsinnig gefährlich trotzdem.
Ja, und wenn du im Fall schon mal rutschst, wirst du einfach zerbissen, oder was, von diesem Drachen.
Ja, aber so wie dieses Doktor-Kroko-mässige Spiel. Es tut leicht weh.
Wie hieß dieses Doktor-Kroko-Spiel nochmal?
Krokodok.
Fast.
Das war unser Safe-Hort übrigens.
Ich weiß, dass Stefan dringend aufs Klo muss.
Krokodok.
Krokodok war unser Safe-Hort. Hat eine Weile gedauert, aber du hast es da hingeschaut. Kroko-MD.
Aber ich kann mir nur vorstellen, dass die Zunge der Rutschbereich ist.
Ich fand Rutschen auch nie cool als Kind, aber so auf der Rutschen.
Ich bin die ein bisschen lehm immer, ehrlich gesagt.
Kann man die Zunge so muskulös trainieren, dass man erstickt daran? Oh Gott, ey. Nee, weißt du mal, nee, sorry. Jürgen Tienzmann hat seine Zunge verschluckt, das weisst du. Oh Gott, hör auf. Ja, das ist eine wahre Geschichte. Und hat er sich selber aufgegessen? Nee, Leute haben ihm geholfen, Vereinskameraden haben ihm geholfen, mussten ihn wieder auf rechts drehen. Kannst du kurz bitte? Wenn du deine Zunge überschluckst, drehst du dich einmal, du krempelst dich um. Ja, wie so ein Katzenohr, wo du nur so blip, einmal flipp und dann selber wieder. Aber ich meine, wenn du Bodybuilder bist, du hast ja wahrscheinlich nicht angefangen. Ja, da kann ich mich sehr gut mit ihr identifizieren. Nee, aber erzähl du mal, du hattest ja wahrscheinlich nicht von Anfang an an diesen Körper vor Augen, sondern du gehst ins Fitnessstudio und denkst, ja, ich will ein bisschen in Form kommen, will besser dastehen, will irgendwie nicht Rückenschmerzen haben, wenn ich mal eine Treppe hochgehe oder so. Genau, Rückenschmerzen, der häufigste Grund immer, ich glaube, Rückenschmerzen sind der häufigste vorgestorbene Grund ins Fitnessstudio, über diesen Beratungsgesprächen am Anfang, wo alle eigentlich immer nur denken, ja, ich will besser aussehen, aber alle sagen, ja, hier Rückenschmerzen. Ja, und dann fängst du an und trainierst und trainierst und wirst immer breiter und denkst dann, irgendwann kommst du da rein. Was passiert, wenn das auch mit der Zunge passiert? Wenn du anfangst und du denkst, ich trainiere die Zunge ein bisschen, einfach um schneller essen zu können? Weil kannst du schneller verdauen, wenn du Bauchmuskeln hast? Nein. Gar, wirklich nicht. Nein. Ich bin mir so sicher, dass es nicht so funktioniert. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Körpern, aber ich bin mir so sicher. Was machen die denn dann? Ich glaube, die haben keine Bewandtnis. Ich glaube, die sind gesundheitlich sogar eher nachteilig. Aber irgendwie muss doch das gesteuert werden, was im Bauch passiert. Ja, wahrscheinlich macht das nee, ja, wahrscheinlich macht das der Darm. Ja, aber der braucht ja auch Muskeln dann, oder nicht? Oder hast du das? Wenn Sie sich nicht von mir behandeln lassen wollen, dann gehen Sie zum anderen Arzt. Sie sind mir zu skeptisch. Sehen Sie die ganzen Bücher im Hintergrund. Herr Doktor, ich habe zwölf Jahre für dieses Eight-Pack gebraucht. Ich dachte, ich könnte damit schneller verdauen. Sie wollen mir sagen, das ist zu nichts gut? Ich kann nicht mal schneller Stuhl gehen? Sie können schneller, wenn Sie liegen, können Sie schneller sich so zusammenklappen. Oder du kannst einfacher häufig deine Beine so hochklappen. Wenn ich mit meiner Freundin telefoniere, dann kann ich meine Knie so hochziehen. Genau, wenn Sie mit Ihrer besten Freundin telefonieren, können Sie besser diese Geste machen. Ja, oder die andere, die ich... Präsentieren wir das mal?
Ja.
Die eine...
So, die ist gut, aber welcher auch gut ist, ist die und dann so.
Ne, aber das kommt immer...
Und wechseln.
Das kommt bei Themenwechseln und oder spannenden Sachen.
Also wir reden jetzt irgendwie über Tobi, weil Tobi ist süss.
Ja, Tobi finde ich wirklich süss.
Und dann immer, es ist eigentlich wie ein Hundeschwanz, sobald irgendwie ein neues Thema aufkommt, was dir gefällt, musst du mehr Bewegung haben.
Also wenn ein Thema langweilig wird, wir reden jetzt über Hausaufgaben, dann wird die Rotation ein bisschen geringer.
Und dann so, ey, aber was ich noch mal sagen wollte, ne, Tobi war heute so süss. Wirklich? Ja, ne. Der sitzt ja in Biologie, sitzt ja vor mir, ne. Ja. Und der war so süss. Und heute hat er sich einmal umgeritten und hat mich gefragt, was ich später mache. Wirklich? Und was hast du gesagt? Dass ich mit dir telefoniere. Aber sag mal, was hältst du eigentlich von Stefan? Oh, Stefan ist so... Er ist viel zu cool. Ich traue mich nicht, Stefan anzusprechen. Moment, heisst das, du bist anderer Meinung, wenn du das dann umdrehst? Du kannst mich sehen? Wir Videocallen! Du kannst mich sehen! Wir FaceTime! Du liest meine Füsse! Wir sind vierzehnjährige Girls, wir facetimen! Körpersprache, es ist so wichtig, es ist so wichtig. Glaubst du an so Körpersprachenkram? Ja! Da gibt es dann immer so Seminare und so von wegen, ja ich lüge oder oder irgendwie so. Das ist ein kleiner Tipp, wenn er es so macht, ist es wahrscheinlich eine Lüge und alles. Oder er meint es so ernst. Nein, ich will Team-Captain werden. Okay, alles klar, ich glaub dir. Aber glaubst du wirklich an sowas, so man spielt dann so und... Geheime Signale. Ja, wirklich? Geh da mal bitte drauf ein. Na, ich glaube, dass wir auch gerade Dinge machen, die wir in echten Situationen nicht machen würden. Wirklich? Ja, weil auf Bühnen vergisst man, wie man sich bewegt. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich sehr häufig so mache, nie im echten Leben würde ich so machen. Aber hier auf der Bühne habe ich schon so oft, das ist mir aufgefallen, während ich gerade gesprochen habe, dass ich häufig so mache, what is this? Nicht mal, wenn man ihm eine wirklich schockierende Botschaft überbringt, macht er so. Gar nichts. Und vor allem denke ich so nach, wenn das mein neues Nachdenken ist, wie ich mich umbringe. Wenn ich was nachdenken, und ich stehe dann so irgendwo. Jesus, was ist denn für der Geist? Ich meine, Stefan, ich muss dir ganz wichtig sagen, die Show heute Abend muss abgesagt werden, leider. Da wäre es dann schon, das wäre eben das Wichtigste. Das passt, ne? Das ist das Schönste. Ja, aber meinst du, man kann ablesen aus unserer Körpersprache, was wir denken? Nervosität würde ich mal behaupten. Ob wir zu irgendetwas geboren sind oder nicht? Wenn das nach wie vor dein Curling ist, dann bist du dafür nicht geboren, glaube ich. Es ist mehr Bowling eigentlich. Weil du meintest gerade, dass du mit deinen Brüdern dann mit Hockeyschlägern auf diesen See gegangen bist, auf diesen super gefährlichen See. Ja. Und gab es da auch Leute, die Curling gespielt haben. Mir ist auch jetzt in dem Moment gerade, 20 Jahre später gekommen, wir hätten einfach mit diesen Hockeyschlägern gucken können, ob es... Ja. Das ist die längste Idee. Stattdessen haben sie ihn bei dich genommen und geworfen. Ja, genau, einfach direkt. Den jüngsten. Krack, krack, ist doch nicht so dick. Krack, krack, krack. Nein, wir haben Eishockey gespielt. Ja, was heißt Eishockey gespielt? Mein Bruder hat Eishockey gespielt. Der Rest hat ums Überleben gekämpft im eingebrochenen See. Meine Aufgabe war es, den Puck zu holen, wenn er ihn neben das Tor geschossen hat. Dr. Kroc, wirf kein Mikrofon. Nein, nein, nein, mein ich nicht. Aber das ist das Leben eines kleinen Bruders. Du musst assistieren deinem Bruder, der Spaß hat. Du bist nur der Assistent. Du hältst nur die Chipsbox und machst den Level, wenn er zu schwer ist für deinen Bruder. Aber willst du glauben, dass du gerade quasi das übernommen hast ein bisschen, dass du Leuten, weil du bist Unterhalter, du bist ein Beobachter. du guckst Leuten zu, wie sie ihr normales Leben leben und reflektierst dann auf der Bühne darüber. Ist es nicht das, was deine Rolle als kleiner Bruder, die du da übernommen hast? Ja, kann gut sein, auf jeden Fall. Dafür kriegen sie 70 Euro in der Stunde. Ich meine, sie haben Recht, sie haben immer Recht, aber sie haben halt auch meine Autobiografie gelesen, also Sie haben Recht.
Ich habe Ihre Autobiografie gelesen.
Machen das Therapeuten manchmal, dass sie so cheaten, einfach so, naja, Sie hatten ja bestimmt auch eine schwere Kindheit, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, stimmt, vor allem mit Ihrem Bruder Beffern. Ja, Beffern.
Und vor allem haben Sie sehr unter der Unkreativität Ihrer Eltern gelitten, weil er so heisst wie sein Bruder, meine Leute.
Sie haben doch Christ, mein Gott, wir verteilen alle Gags nochmal als PDF nach der Sitzung, können wir nochmal nachlesen,
sitzen ja in dem Zug und sagen, na geil, jetzt heisst er schon.
Sie haben doch als Kind diese Zaubererschule besucht. Ja, tatsächlich. Ach so, nee, sorry, jetzt habe ich ein Buch vertan. Sie waren doch der mit dem Bogen, der bei Elrond... Nein, überhaupt nicht. Gar nicht. Ja gut, jetzt gehen wir sämtliche literarische Referenzen an. Ich kenne die beiden. Sie haben doch mit Jack Sparrow. Ich habe jetzt angefangen. Captain Jack Sparrow. Ah, also das waren Sie. Sie haben recht, Sie kennen mich wie niemand. Ja, ich habe Ihren Film nochmal geguckt. Ja, wie hat Ihnen gefallen? Die Szene mit der Pistole, wie fanden Sie das? Das war überraschend, ne? Nee, weil ehrlich gesagt, im Akt 1 wurde gesagt, dass Sie nur einen Schuss haben und ich dachte mir so direkt... Und da haben Sie schon gewusst, dass ich am Ende den Kapitän Spoiler bei Bossa erschieße. Ja, ich dachte mir so, wir werden natürlich am Ende wahrscheinlich den Typen besiegen mit diesem einen Schuss, den er am Anfang als Feind etabliert hat. Ah, okay, ja schade. Lame ass. Ich dachte, aber die Effekte waren cool, oder? Wie die da so hochfliegt, cool. Ja, das war das Coolste, ja. Ja, wie die da so hochflogen ist, ne? Verrückt. Alles praktisch, kein CGI, die ist einfach hochgestoßen worden. Wenn du aus dem Kino gehst, hörst du dann gern den Leuten zu, wenn die über den Film sprechen, den sie gerade gesehen haben, oder hörst du denen nicht so gerne zu? Ne, ich versuche nur, wie ich mich möglichst lange um ein Urteil herumdrücken kann. Ja? Ja, wo ich dann einfach, erinnere dich an irgendwas, sag einfach, ja, also ich fand die Cinematographie war einfach toll. Also einfach so Worte, so die Urteile mit denen... Sag Bilder, sag, ich fand die Bilder schön. Ja, ja, genau. Also ne, also ich fand das Pacing toll. Also das Pacing hat mir gar nicht gefallen. Ja, ne, nicht. Das fand ich total blöd. Das war viel zu schlecht gepacet. Also im ersten Pace dachte ich mir schon, oh Leute. Aber jeder von uns war doch in einem Alter, wo Leute schon Sachen benutzt haben, Wörter benutzt haben nach dem Kinobesuch, wo man selber noch keine Ahnung hatte. Und ich habe in mein Freundschaftsbuch reingeschrieben, was wollen Sie mal werden, Regisseur. habe ich reingeschrieben, aber trotzdem keine Ahnung, aber ich kann das Wort. Hast du falsch reingeschrieben, mit Öl? Ich habe es richtig reingeschrieben, ich habe nochmal nachgeguckt. Man darf Friseur, Friseur kann man jetzt mit Öl schreiben, ja auch, kann man bestimmt auch Regisseur auch jetzt mit Öl schreiben. Oh ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, dafür habe ich als Achtjähriger nicht mir dieses Wort extra auf die Hand geschrieben, um jeden Tag bei Stephanie vorbeizulaufen, die mit ihren Freundinnen des Toysi-Album geschrieben hat. Wieso kommen Sie zuerst auf den Namen Stephanie? Weil ich einfach nicht sehr wahnsinnig kreativ bin und mit einem Stephan rede. Oder weil du mehr Gefühle für mich hast, als zugeben willst. Das kann auch sein, ja. Vor allem so viele Fanfiction, wuuu! Ja. Gibt's Fanfiction über uns? Auf jeden Fall nicht. Ja, allerdings, allerdings, japp. Hahaha. Ja. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. Ja. Für mich vor allem ganz, also kurz mal Feedback an die Fanfiction-Autorinnen und Autoren da draussen. Da ist alles stockdunkel hier. Einfach für die Leute hier mal. Kleines Feedback an der Stelle mal. Du bist der coolste Dude. Und zwar, weil es ist natürlich, bei Fanfiction geht es um Sex, so ist es nun mal, und das Problem ist natürlich, als Autorin oder Autor hat man halt ein Problem, man kann nicht immer und immer wieder dieselben Wörter benutzen. Und deswegen gibt es eine Formulierung, die nur in Fanfiction auftaucht, um über das Genital zu sprechen. Es gibt nur an diesem Ort gibt es diesen Begriff und es ist die Mitte. Es ist wirklich, ah, manche lächeln auf, manche lächeln auf, weil sie es kennen aus irgendwelchen Sailor-Bruppen oder was. Aber trauen Sie sich nicht zu lachen vor Ihren Freunden, die jetzt dabei sind. Ich lese sowas denn nicht. Ja, und es ist immer, es ist so strange, Fanfiction zu lesen. Also es reicht der Mitte eigentlich ein Swingerclub. Ja, absolut, es ist so, er setzte sich auf meinen Schoss und ich war seiner Mitte noch nie so nah. Und du denkst dir so, was? Selbst das Wort Schoß war anzüglicher. Ja, es ist absolut lächerlich. Also man kann fast schon so ein Bingo-Spiel machen. Bevor ihr Fanfiction liest, schreibt euch 16 Begriffe aus, die euch einfallen würden, um das Genital zu umschreiben. Und dann guckt mal, wie ihr falsch liegt, weil die Leute sind kreativer. Beste, was ich gelesen habe, Äquator. Kein Witz, ich will nicht sagen, in welcher Fanfiction, weil das wäre viel zu peinlich, aber da wurde auch... Flut der Karibik, Will Turner und Johnny Depp. Ja, vor allem es gibt ja so Fanfiction, also es gibt ja diesen Unterbereich des Shippings. Ich bin auf Seite von Johnny Depp.
Bei Will Turner jetzt.
Okay, ja, okay, gut.
Wir können es ja schneiden, je nachdem wie der Prozess ausgeht.
Können wir ja gucken.
Kein Problem, wir haben das Ton alles in Ordnung. Wir müssen eh viel mehr rückblickend verändern im Podcast.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Weil man es einfach machen kann.
Ja, man hätte es schon ankündigen können irgendwie.
Ja.
Oder einfach mal so Dinge streuen, die dann vielleicht passieren.
Wie zum Beispiel im Oktober 2024, wo aus dem Nichts ein Asteroid auftaucht und wählt, oder? Komm, bitte, kriegen das hin. Du hoffst auf den Asteroid? Wir sterben dann. Du hoffst es, damit du gerecht behalten hast im Podcast. Nein, nein, der Asteroid, und dann können die Physiker sagen, ja, ja, ja, wir haben das ausgerechnet und so, das ist kein Problem, der Asteroid wird durch die Atmosphäre durchgehen, wird dann schrumpfen signifikant, aber immer noch eine lebenszerstörende Größe haben, allerdings dann auf dem Ozean auftitschen und dann wie so aus dem See so titscht und dann einfach so weg und wieder in die Galaxie hinaus. Alles was wir machen ... Und dann noch gegen den Mond und dann so tsch ... Genau. Wie dieser Bildschirmhintergrund eigentlich. Ja genau, stimmt. Negativ. Der Nachteil, wir verlieren den Mond. Er wird auftischen, den Mond rauskegeln, schön in 500 Lichtjahren in die Tasche rein, aber dann ist er weg. Sind wir bereit, den Mond zu opfern? Ganz im Ernst, würde die NASA auch nur irgendein Herrchen krümmen, um den fucking Mond zu retten? Nee, why? Wir würden nichts tun. Da ist nicht so viel drauf, was uns viel wert ist. Nee, zwei Flaggen und ein Hammer-Roboter, von dem wir uns dann ganz emotional verabschieden müssen. Ja, genau. Discovery war eine schöne Zeit, vielleicht sieht man sich nochmal. Würdest du den Mond abgeben dafür, für so eine coole Asteroiden-Experience, das mal zu sehen? Also angenommen die Rechnen aus, es kommt ein Asteroid auf die Erde und der Mond wirft sich, also weil er einfach da dran ist, zum richtigen Zeitpunkt so vor die Erde, wäre auch geil. Ja, der Mond rettet uns von einem, ja das wäre gut. Aber allein dafür, würdest du auf den Mond verzichten, dafür, dass du mal sowas erleben kannst? Sofort, sofort, ja, sofort.
Der Mond bedeutet mir nichts.
Ich meine, stellt euch eine Welt ohne Ebbe und Flut vor.
Es ist das gelebte Paradies, oder?
Es ist das, alle unsere Probleme wären wie weggeschwemmt, wenn es Ebbe und Flut nicht mehr gäbe.
Es wäre endlich mal Friede auf dieser Erde.
Der Bootsführerschein, den ich jetzt nach meinem machen muss, wäre so viel einfacher zu erlernen, wenn es Ebbe und Flut nicht gäbe.
Du kannst dir das sparen. Eine Inflation an Bootsführerscheinen natürlich, dann wäre deiner nicht mehr so viel wert. Das stimmt, ja. Natürlich schwierig. Wer wird den Mond abgeben? Wer mag den Mond? Mag irgendwer, wer will den Mond unbedingt behalten? Ja, Stefan, ganz kurz, also jetzt um euch in Schutz zu nehmen, ihr drei Weirdos, die unter den Bedingungen in die Hand gehoben habt, deine Definition von Asteroiden-Erfahrung war auch einfach ein bisschen dünn. Deine Frage, diese klassische Partyfrage, die man sich nach fünf Bieren in der WG-Küche stellt. Sag mal, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, würdest du den Mond abgeben? Nee, jetzt denk mal das Bier weg, Tom. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, ich will, dass du ehrlich antworten. Alle hören dir zu. Würdest du, nee, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey noch nichts, okay, hör dir erstmal die Frage an.
Würdest du den Mond abgeben für eine Asteroiden-Experience? Nein, das habe ich so nicht gefragt. Was hast du erst Asteroiden-Erfahrung? Für eine richtig coole Asteroiden-Erfahrung. Okay, und wenn du sagst, ah shit, Mond, Asteroiden-Erfahrung, Mond, was würde ich machen? na ja, ich sag mal so, so ein riesigen planetenähnliches Ding auf uns herabregnen zu sehen. Und im letzten Moment kommt dann der Mond und schiebt sich so davor und man sieht zwei riesige Himmelskörper kollidieren in der Luft. Und die ganze Welt guckt das und man wird sich an die Wörter erinnern von den Kommentatoren, so Peter-Urban-artigen Kommentatoren, die dieses Ereignis dann kommentieren. Der das übersetzen muss und dann nach fünf Minuten Stille, bumm, krach, krach, rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts. Aber das will doch jeder mal sehen, halt mit dem Nachdenken, dass danach der Mond weg ist. Ja. Also, mit diesem Hintergrund nochmal, wer würde den Mond opfern für eine Asteroiden-Erfahrung? Eins, zwei, wow, zwei Besucher. So wenig Bock. Ihr habt eine schöne Heimfahrt gemeinsam gleich. Ihr könnt euch richtig ausquatschen. Oh, wie geil wäre das, eine Asteroiden-Erfahrung. Stell dir vor, der kommt und dann haben wir eine Erfahrung zusammen. Wow, das wäre richtig toll. Lass danach noch was trinken gehen einfach, da können wir dann darüber reden irgendwie. Ja, ihr drei, ihr macht zusammen Podcast einfach, ihr die Asteroiden-Erfahrung. Die Asteroiden-Experience. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber du hast gesagt, die können alle sehen, nur die halbe Erde können das sehen und die andere Erde nicht. Ganz einfach nur die von der Hälfte können das sehen und die anderen müssen es sehen. Ich glaube, die werden... Blöd wären halt die, die so ganz am Rand wären, die so... Rita, das wird die Geste sein. Halt mich mal fest, Rita. Jetzt gleich es soweit. Ich würde es auch so gerne mal sehen, wirklich. Du hast gesagt, wir kippen um, wir kippen auf die andere Seite des Planeten. Jetzt gleich ist es... Und beschreibt, wie es aussieht. Bumm, das war's. Das war eine tolle Erfahrung. Was sind das für Leute, die am Rand stehen? Das sind die Äquatorleute, diese versauten Äquatorleute. Diese versauten Mittelleute. Äquator. Berlin-Mitte kriegt eine ganz andere Bedeutung. Oh Gott. Vor allem, es gibt ja in Fanfiction noch das Untergenre des Shippings. Bedding. Des Shippings, das bedeutet, du nimmst zwei Figuren, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben, und drückst die zusammen. Also verkuppelst die in deiner Fantasie. Und dann gibt es die weirdesten Shippings, du hast dann halt irgendwie so Sailor Mars und Elmo, die halt dann sich zufällig, cute meat mässig, Elmo fallen die Orangen runter, Sailor Mars kommt, oh, lass mich dir helfen. Und, ha, ha. Und dann voll mit dem Gesicht in die Mitte von Elmo. Ja, genau. Und Elmo so, holy shit, ey. Ja, und es sind einfach die ruhigsten Kombinationen, aber trotzdem sehr erotisch, also muss man sagen. Aber ist Elmo dann trotzdem noch eine Puppe? Gute Frage. Was macht der Puppenspieler zu der Zeit? Gibt's eigentlich, ich meine, es gibt ja diese Internetregel, dass es von allem auch Pornos gibt. Gibt es Sesamstrassenpornos und wenn ja, wer macht da die Puppenspieler? Nee, die Puppenspieler bumsen und die Figuren haben die beiseite gelegt. Ja, das kann sein. Das Problem, also kleines Feedback an der Stelle nochmal, vielleicht ist der Autor unter uns, aber das Problem an Elmo ist halt, er trägt keine Kleidung. Nee, genau, er ist so nackt. Also die Erotik ist ja auch oft, kommt daher, dass halt noch, sag ich mal, Dinge verborgen sind und mit Fantasie angeregt wird. Bei Elmo halt, du weißt, was du kriegst. Moment, nee, nee. Beim ersten Date bei Elmo, es gibt erstens keine Enttäuschung, aber zweitens halt auch keine positive Überraschung.
Bei Elmo ist alles da.
Aber Hunde sind ja auch immer nackt. Und Hunde, bei Hunden gibt es manchmal grosse Überraschungen.
Okay, geh da mal bitte nicht näher drauf ein.
Hatte ich nicht vor.
Gut, dann haben wir das ja auch abgeschlossen.
Abgeschlossen, ne?
Aber, danke schön. Das Thema ist vorbei. Aber gerade nochmal Shitstorm abgewendet. Dafür kriegen wir den Shitstorm für Hunde. Wir sind nicht so ein zotiger Podcast, der sich viel traut. Wenn wir Shitstorms bekommen, dann wegen Hundepenissen. Und unserem Merch aus Bangladesch. Ah, okay. Schaut bitte nicht auf die Etiketten, bitte, bitte tut uns im Gefahr. Du meinst, Elmo hat so eine richtige rote Rakete noch am Start? Ja, stell dir so einen Lippenstift vor, den du so rückartig ausfährst. Aber auch die Drehbewegung auch mehr. Oh Gott! Zip, ich kann noch weitermachen. Zip, die ganze Nacht, Baby, zip. Seine Mitte schoss schraubenförmig heraus. Ich will doch gut Mitte sagen, aber dann super explizit beschreiben, wie es aussieht. Seine Mitte wuchs und wuchs, dachte Sailor Mars. Seine Mitte schrob sich aus dem Lippenstift. Wie ein Weinöffner, der meine Seele öffnete. Man sagt nicht Weinöffner, ne? So wenig Ahnung von Weinen. Wie ein Weinöffner. Ich bin immer so unkult. Stefan immer so vor der Sennung. Sein Wein und Vino Bianco und Ciclaro und Prost und dann wird über irgendwie die Winzerreien geredet. Und dann Prost, ne? Wir Sommeliers, wie Weinkondition und dann Prost. Prösterstück. Ich verstehe nicht, was die sagen, was soll das bedeuten? Was soll Prost bedeuten? Ja, was soll das? Was ist das? Was trinkt ihr da immer? Und ich mit meiner Fritz-Cola-Light stehe dann immer so, ja, die ist natürlich auch ein ganz guter Jahrgang hier auf jeden Fall. 2022er, nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Nee, ich kenne mich da jetzt auch nicht so gut aus. Ich kenne mich da jetzt auch nicht. Wenn man lügt, übrigens auch ein gutes Telling ist sehr tief sprechen fest. Naja, ich bin selbst auch gar nicht so viel, wie jetzt überhaupt es. Was eigentlich der Trick ist, du musst ja versuchen, deine Zuhörer dahingehend zu Mal eben… Hast du ein Ticket, oder warum kommen sie jetzt aus unserer Seitentür heraus? Da ist jemand, der hier arbeitet. Oder er hat sich einfach gerade hart geirrt und dachte, ich bin irgendwie richtig falsch abgewogen gerade. Wo bin ich denn hier? Wo bin ich denn richtig? Wollte du nur zum Supermarkt? Ja, wie Leute, die mal bei Faisal Kawusi gelandet sind, aber eigentlich zu... Ne, umgekehrt. Die wollten zu... Doch, die wollten zu... Kein Faisal Kawusi, sind dann bei uns gelandet. Ja, waren bei uns. Und sind dann bei uns geblieben, die ganze Show. Und ich denke mir so, yes, wir wachsen ganz langsam, weil in jeder Show sich zwei Leute verirren. Ja, vor allem die auch einfach nach zehn Minuten dachten, ja, der kommt gleich noch. Aber ich fand das so lustig, die Vorstellung, dass du irgendwo hinfährst, eine Stunde mit dem Auto, die Tickets hast, dann in eine andere Lokalität gehst, siehst, da passiert gerade was anderes und dann da bleibst. Nee, absolut. Für zwei Stunden. Ja, das ist nicht Phantom der Oper, das ist irgendwie, das funktioniert nicht. Aber es ist schwierig. Gibt es denn Leute, die eigentlich heute woanders hinwollten, die andere Ziele hatten? Ist natürlich auch verwirrend, mit der anderen Halle direkt nebenan wo Limbisket spielt,
und deswegen bin ich skeptisch gegenüber jedem Limbisket-T-Shirt, das ich sehe,
weil ich denke mir, echte Fans könnt ihr nicht sein, sonst werdet ihr nicht hier, sonst werdet ihr nebenan.
Hört ihr den polternden Bass von nebenan? Lass es mal ganz ruhig sein, das wir doch mal hören.
Und dann geht die Tür so ab.
Lass es mal ganz ruhig sein. Jeder kennt das doch auf dem Klo. Lass es mal ganz ruhig sein. Lass es mal ganz ruhig sein. Sorry. Es ist so eine ungelernte Situation, dass man wieder sagt. Lass es mal gucken, ob wir die Nachbarn... Ich mache schon wieder diese Geste. What the fuck? Hink mir die Hand. Wir schauen mal, ob wir die Nachbarn hören. Ruhe jetzt bitte. Ich höre Klimaanheben. Nee, gar nichts. Wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig. Aber es ist auch schwierig, weil ich habe letztens nachgedacht so, ja, ich meine, man kennt das, die Nachbarn, die, sag ich mal, ja, sehr laut Geschlechtsverkehr haben. Ab welchem Punkt kann man … Kannst du es ein bisschen mehr Fanfiction-mäßig ausdrücken? Also die, wo zwei Mitten sich treffen, laut, mit Überschall … Also man könnte sich nicht mehr in der Mitte treffen. Mit Überschallgeschwind. Die beiden Nachbarn haben einen Streit gehabt und dann haben sie sich in der Mitte getroffen. Ja, sehr schön. Das ist eine schöne Umschreibung. Ich glaube, du wärst ein richtig guter Fanfiction-Autor. Ich glaube auch, ehrlich gesagt. Wie so von Rockos modernes Leben und Marge Simpson oder irgendwie sowas. So eine ganz weirde Kombi, die auch viel zu viel Einblicke in dein erotisches Verständnis gibt einfach.
Aber man fragt sich, wann kann man
realistischerweise rübergehen und das
ansprechen oder hat man gar keine Chance.
Ist das ein akutes Problem bei dir?
Es ist ein Problem, ja.
Die treffen sich in der Mitte und du sagst,
scheiße, kannst du doch nicht schlafen?
Nee, du kannst nichts machen.
Wie lange danach wartet man, bis man klingelt und sagt, freut mich, aber... Sie kennen zu lernen, wir wohnen seit 19 Jahren nebeneinander. Weil ich sag mal so, ich halte mich zurück, Ihnen zuliebe auch. Ich denke, also... Ich halte mich nun seit sieben Jahren wegen Ihnen zurück.
Ja.
Das ist der einzige Grund.
Ich sage auch, also das ist meine Art von Dirty Talk, bitte nicht zu laut, die Nachbarn.
Bitte nicht zu laut, auch während des Aktes einfach, weil das ist mir wichtig.
Bei mir ist das Gegenteil, bitte laut, damit die Nachbarn denken, okay, Stefan, bei Stefan ist noch alles okay.
Was machst du mit dem Megafon?
Nee, wenn du dich bitte ein bisschen mehr in diese Richtung drehen könntest. Warum machst du alle Fenster auf? Ich werde gerade, glaub ich, voyeuristisch belästigt. Oh, du bist angeschaut? Das wollte ich eigentlich sagen. Ich habe auch manchmal das Gefühl, beobachtet zu werden. Es ist so ein ganz dünnes... Ich habe das Gefühl, ich werde angeguckt. Wirklich? Quatsch, wer denn? Die sind alle hier für Limbiske, mach dir keine Sorgen. Die haben alle noch Hoffnung, die gucken alle nicht. Es ist mir zum ersten Mal aufgefallen, wenn ich in meinem Bett liege und abends zum Beispiel noch eine Serie gucke und aus dem Fenster schaue, gibt es eine andere Wohnung, die da reingucken kann. Okay. So, und wenn man dann abends halt noch nicht pennt oder sowas und da ist noch alles offen, kann er reingucken, dann habe ich irgendwie mal, war auch ein Horrorfilm oder sowas geschaut und schaue dann so hoch von meinem Laptop und sehe einfach so einen Mann im Fenster. Und ich weiss, ich weiss, dass der Fotograf ist. Ich weiss wirklich, es ist kein Scheiss, der ist Fotograf, weil es, ja, woher weisst du das denn? Ja, Entschuldigung, dass ich das nicht mehr kenne. Ja, weil es ab und zu blitzt. Also er hat auch manchmal … Okay. Okay. Er hat manchmal Models da und so, die sind dann auf seinem Balkon und so was. Und dann, der hat auch so ein Fotostudio und Equipment und man sieht dann so … Warte. Und man sieht dann auch so, er hat so grosse Softlights und so was und hat auch so seine Kameraequipment und so was. Es ist nicht so weit weg, man sieht, dass er Fotograf ist. Und wenn aber diese Person dann abends da steht und so, dann ist er auch da eine Laterne, deswegen kann man da nicht mehr so genau reingucken, aber er war jedenfalls da. Und ich bin der Meinung, dass da auch so ein Stativ stand. So, und jetzt ist Folgendes passiert. Über Ostern war ich in meiner Heimat und habe dann so ein paar Sachen durchgeguckt, die ich noch so hatte und habe ein altes Fernglas gefunden. Okay, das Aufrüsten hat begonnen, ja. Das habe ich mir dann mit nach Köln genommen, einfach als Verteidigung, weil meine Idee war... So fangen solche Sachen an, ja, als Verteidigung, Notwehr. Ein rein Selbstverteidteidigungsfernglas. Ich habe mir das mitgenommen und habe das jetzt in dem Bett gelegt. Und da habe ich einmal schon mal das Gefühl gehabt, dass der wieder da so steht. Und dann habe ich das Fernglas genommen und geguckt. Wie gesagt, da ist halt diese Laterne dazwischen. Das heißt, man kann nicht, es ist wahnsinnig geblendet, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich genau da reingeguckt habe, aber meine Idee war, dass wenn er dann da auch steht mit einer Kamera oder sowas und dann mich sieht, wie ich im Bett liege, den Laptop, den Film pausiert habe und dann mit so einer Kamera, mit so einem Fernglas dann da schaue und er guckt dann so mit der Kamera und sieht dann mich, wie ich mit dem Fernglas im Bett liege, dann fühlt er sich ja ertappt. Aber dann ist die Frage, wer verklagt dann weh?
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Wahrscheinlich gerade bei irgendeinem anderen Live-Podcast erzählt irgendwie ein Fotograf,
ich habe diesen weirden Nachbarn, der guckt mich immer einfach mit seinem Fernglas an die ganze Zeit.
The lamest Mexican Stand-Off aller Zeiten.
Zwei Leute, schauen Sie sich einfach nur an.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich da rauskomme.
Jetzt habe ich ein Fernglas zu selbst verteidigen.
Aber ich meine, also ist es jetzt für dich eine Motivation, dein Leben zu verändern,
um besser dazustehen vor ihm oder so, dass du das nochmal ein bisschen ihm auch was zeigen
Vielen Dank. wenn ich da rauskomme. Jetzt habe ich ein Fernglas zur Selbstverteidigung. Aber ich meine, also ist es jetzt für dich eine Motivation, dein Leben zu verändern, um besser dazustehen vor ihm oder so, dass du das nochmal ein bisschen ihm auch was zeigen möchtest oder so? Ja, deswegen beim Sex jetzt auch immer die Vorhänge auf. Ja, okay. Oh, das ist aber jemand sehr selbstbewusst. Ja. Und du siehst ihn, aber er macht auch das Licht bei sich an, wenn er schaut. Diese Lacher finde ich so gemein.
Nicht nur du hast die Fotos von ihm gesehen, also ich sag mal, die sind mittlerweile ruhig gegangen. Aber kann ja sein, dass Fotos auftauchen irgendwann von dir?
Kann jetzt sein, ja.
Bist du da vorbereitet?
Ja, aber wie googelt man dann danach oder bei Pornseiten oder sowas?
Also mein Name wird ja dann nicht dabei stehen, oder? Weil den weiss er ja nicht.
Ach so, du meinst, wenn du jetzt so von so einem Voyeur einfach gefilmt worden wirst. Also was muss ich eingeben? Und dann musst du sehr, sehr ehrlich sein. Tall, hot stud. In Cologne. Aber Cologne würde auch nicht dabei stehen. Too tall, too hot. Too tall to handle. Ja. Ist das deine Autobiografie? Ja. Ist das, hat das dein Therapeut neben seinem Tisch liegen, too tall to handle? Das ist die Stefan-Tietze-Autobiographie, auch heute hier erhältlich am Merch. Ja, genau. Könnt ihr euch einkaufen mit vielen tollen Fotos, vor allem im Mittelteil des Buches. Vor allem die Mittel, die Mittel, grosse Mittel. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank Berlin, ihr wart fantastisch, das war unser Abend. Schön, vielen Dank, schön, dass ihr da wart, haut rein! Dankeschön, es war unser... Flore Zidwill! Und natürlich der einzigartige Stefan Kietze! Vielen Dank, macht's gut! Danke, dass Sie da waren, kommt gut nach Hause, haut rein.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, sehr viel Spaß.
Macht's gut, macht's gut, schönen Abend, tschau!